guys we've got breaking news here a
headline from Breitbart
Jim Carrey has left Twitter my God Jim
Carrey has left Twitter Kurt how are you
going to stay on a platform without Jim
Carrey how are you gonna do it I'm
trying to find the strength to move
forward Dave
um
wow
I you know sometimes you're just
speechless
um well okay so I'll I won't push you
that hard on the Jim Carrey thing but
this idea that suddenly these people
Alyssa Milano is freaking out and you
know all of these again these
quote-unquote journalists we're gonna
leave Twitter and it's like no you're
not going to leave Twitter because you
guys don't have the wherewithal to build
anything yourself but that they didn't
care
three weeks ago when we were all getting
censored now they think this is the most
evil thing ever even though there's no
empirical evidence that hate has been
ramped up since he's taken over
I I wouldn't care if hate was ramped up
free speech is Free Speech
period you get to say things other
people don't like Now understand I want
to be real clear this is not hypocrisy
on their part some people are your
Twitter people are hypocrites no they're
not they don't believe in free speech
they are actively against it so is the
regime media they are actively for
censorship
and they're upset because Elon Musk came
along and bought
their BS line of reasoning
Melissa what do you think about that
because uh we have a lot of similar
friends or had some similar friends that
were you know thought of as more liberal
that suddenly really kind of are tacitly
or sometimes outwardly coming out for
censorship or not respecting views and
having that plurality of use it's
disappointing to say the least
you know firstly I haven't thought about
Jim Carrey in a long time so it's kind
of like there was this moment of
lightweight who is this person
um
yeah no I'm yes I imagine him coming out
of a rhino right now like that's just
you know the image but
but this whole thing about celebrities
kind of threatening to you know leave
Twitter it's it's it's so shallow and
it's so Hollow I mean Elisa Milano said
oh I'm gonna sell my Tesla I'm buying a
Volkswagen hilarious because obviously
what is the history of Volkswagen it was
awkward
um and and she's she's Tweeting or she's
still using an iPhone right but she's
grandiosely announcing that she's
leaving Twitter this iPhone the one that
she's using has all sorts of problems
Apple was found to have been using
sourcing parts of this iPhone from
xinjiang which is where they're they're
you know the uyghurs are being held and
and they're involved in like the
production of some of these parts
um and and even though the the White
House has passed the uh the uyghur force
labor prevention act and she's still
using an iPhone and she's not
complaining about all these components
that go into this that actually affect
you know marginalized actually
marginalized people and so it just Rings
very Hollow to me all this kind of
posturing about like leaving Twitter
um and and with regard to what you're
saying about our friends who um you know
make huge announcements about leaving
Twitter and and are trending online for
uh you know for for days
um well I don't know about you but I I
kind of I kind of saw that coming you
know
um especially after a recent viral Clips
uh uh I know we're all talking about Sam
Harris viral Clips but but he you know
in his latest show he did explain why he
left and it's kind of the same argument
that we saw with the The Washington Post
headline that said the gates of hell are
now open with Elon at the helm and you
know Sam claims to to have to leave
because of just dealing with so much
hate on the website and it's turning him
into this awful person he doesn't want
to you know he just doesn't want to be
part of it anymore and I fine that's a
legitimate reason to leave Twitter yeah
I mean I keep telling people as I've
gotten one or two Mean Tweets at me in
the Years you can just mute or block
people or you can actually not look at
your phone all day which is a really
fascinating thing I'm not a doctor but I
think most people can do that